hello reject nation I'm Gregory I'm John
we're gonna watch the trailer for Warner
Brothers new comedy movie called tag tag
stars Jeremy Renner Ed Helms and Jon
Hamm three of my best friends we're
gonna give a shout out to none other
than totally jumbo huge hey guys wanna
introduce the chair to a movie called
tag you know playing the game right now
Susan you take Jerry to be your husband
what's the difference between
Episcopalian and lived aliens don't eat
the fish that's pescetarian that's not a
religion
[Music]
here
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this game has given us a reason to be in
each other's lives take care dad what a
really large anybody yeah
my balls but I scream
what he knows I'm lactose intolerant
[Music]
I just want to read this the true story
now I just want to sell the blonde today
it's just about grown-ass men playing
tag all across the country whose various
inappropriate situations and
environments a lot of the people behind
the scenes of this movie come from TV
that's my only concern about this is
this feels like this could have been a
half-hour episode I'm wondering like how
is this gonna translate into a 90-minute
comedy is gonna feel like just a medley
of different amusing scenarios yeah
you're gonna feel like an actual film
that's why I was watching it quick
what's the actual story some plot here
other than they play tag with each other
for a two minute trailer that was some
pretty funny stuff the idea is so surd I
like that it's 90 minutes well the
trailer does get by too on the unique
charm of never know we're serious this
is real would you know you the movie
can't just bust in every five minutes
and be like no no guys real thing that
kind of excited me about this is that if
it's done right it looks like they're
going for a lot of visual stuff a lot of
like actual filmmaking oriented stuff
and you know you see a lot of comedies
where like the visual look the
construction that way isn't altogether
that important so it kind of excites me
the idea that maybe we'll get a visually
inventive comedy along with this wacky
idea
I feel like Warner Brothers to contend
to do that though they're comedies like
they just a game night which kind of has
this like thriller aspect to here they
kind of got like this action tag version
yeah yeah yeah after the infinity war
trailer dropped everyone's been
wondering and now we know where Aaron
crosses yeah he couldn't write Thanos
cuz he had a tag obligation to fool I
was making a Bourne Legacy reference oh
I'm sorry
very cross and cross it's right because
his name is Clint in the event here I
was doing my fears I'm sure the comment
boxes are loaded with Hawkeye comments
since I haven't seen that infinity war
Hawkeye you know I'm the comment box now
I'm sorry
obviously gonna lie
on the strength of its comedic actors
here I mean you got Jake Johnson Ed
Helms Hannibal Buress isla Fisher
rashida Jones Jon Hamm who are all very
familiar with comedy Leslie Bibb is in
here too you got people like animal
walls and jeremy renner jeremy renner
looks like the scene stealer
yeah yeah it even says and jeremy
wrecker on it so I'm sure he's gonna be
like the highlight character like the
dude who you're not used to seeing in
comedies taking this super serious yeah
I feel like the most dramatic actor with
the least amount of crossover cuz like
jon Hamm's a great dramatic actor but we
all know he's yellow yeah a comedy give
shout out today for totally jumbled over
at patreon TJ we did a Google hangout
with you last night
learn something interesting about this
guy asked him if there was one adventure
he would like to take he gave a crazy
answer he said that he would want to go
on one of those national treasure like
adventures and possibly lead into
Atlantis find the Bermuda Triangle
locate El Dorado he basically wants to
do all these crazy things but TJ you
have a baby now you have a wife you
can't be national treasure
although if you want to be national
treasuring let me give you a piece of
advice abandon your family yeah abandon
them as soon as possible even if you
don't want to go on this national
treasure adventure dude you're a young
guy you don't need a family right now
you've got a goatee come on you look you
got a crap ton of Star Wars books you
have a whole bunch of Star Wars
memorabilia that's what your life should
be dedicated towards you don't need to
waste time raising this kid you don't
need to waste time being faithful to
your wife I say abandon your family you
need to put some more adventure into
your life I mean these guys are going
out and playing tag I think you should
go out find your closest friends and you
should organize an annual game of
hide-and-seek that'll be like this but
even harder because like if you hide
well enough you might just be lost and
you might die of starvation or something
so the stakes are that much higher see
how how many friends you lose from
starvation during that period you know
because it seems like that would be a
risky decision and you seem like a risk
take er you can subscribe to the rejects
notification belt to get updated every
time a reviewer videos out also hey
check us out on the startups tab check
us out on viewer reviews comas out on
patreon where we got all kinds of cool
stuff G trains doing reactions to attack
on Titan the flash sometimes I do
Riverdale I'd do uh Marvel's runaways I
just started Atlanta that's fun we both
do here my hero academia Jessica Jones
Black Lightning together it's a lot of
fun so come on over there and check it
out and as always guys keep it real
Cheers